now here at 6 30 and the race for clark
county commission district c has yet to
be called
democrat and former secretary of state
ross miller ran against republican
and las vegas city council member
stavros anthony miller won by just
10 votes a recount started just a short
time ago and bianca holmen
is live for us at the elections office
with more on that process hi bianca
hey good morning alex so like you said
miller won over anthony by just a slim
margin and so this week we'll determine
if that
lead still remains the recount just
started about over an
hour and a half ago at five a.m this
morning
so here's what happened anthony had a
lead on the election night but that
changed when
more of the mail-in ballots were counted
ross miller
would win by just 10 votes election
officials say they identified 139 voting
errors however the county
still certified the votes last week and
with such a slim margin anthony
called for a recount last week clark
county
voter registrar joe gloria noted how
remarkably close
this race ended up over 150
000 people voted in this contest it's
very out of the ordinary for a race with
that many votes to be decided by
10. that margin of victory is very
difficult to reconcile no matter what
the race is with 215 precincts in it
anthony is hoping to be the first
republican elected to clark county
commission
in 16 years right now democrats have a
seven to nothing advantage
in the commission and now the recur the
recount started
at 5 am this morning and we're told that
the election staff will be
recounting votes for at least 17 and a
half hours
each day up until friday reporting live
bianca holman 8 news now